Fock, ich weiß, ich bin erst da zur später Stunde hier und dann auch nicht mal lange,
weil demnächst Bett gehe, meine Lautstärke ok, sagt mal her, ja Lautstärke ist ok, passt,
weil ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich habe jetzt, übrigens kann sein immer noch, dass
ich zwischendurch mal husten muss, weil immer noch nicht alles gut ist, husten halt technisch,
aber es ist schon besser, jetzt wollte ich jetzt sagen, ja, ihr werdet es nicht glauben,
was ich gemacht habe, ich habe einen Pop-Schutz, einen richtig ordentlichen Pop-Schutz selbst
gebaut jetzt auf dem Mikrofon, hört mal, gar nicht mehr so schlimm wie vorher, zu viele
Tabs, na Moment, Tabs und Tabs, na das ist jetzt ja nicht etwa, da geht es schon noch
deutlich mehr, ich meine unter 8GB RAM macht es meinen Browser eh nicht, das ist richtig,
die Titel, sobald man den Titel erkennt, ist es zu wenig, ja so muss es sein, hier ist
eigentlich auch fast, fast noch, fast noch zu wenig, na ja, aber ich habe gedacht ich
komme mal kurz Küchenschwamm zerschnitten, genau, ich habe einen Schwamm, ich habe mir
einen 3er Pack Schwämme gekauft von Amazon fürs Autowaschen und daraus habe ich jetzt
einen Pop-Schutz gebastelt, ja, dicke Socken ist ganz schön schwierig über ein Headset
Mikro drüber zu wickeln oder, wie viel RAM hast du, 32GB glaube ich, wo sieht man das
noch mal, hier 32GB, ja, RAM ist aktuell das einzige was billig ist, wisst ihr das, also
billig, in Anführung billig, RAM ist das einzige was man sich zur Zeit zu halbwegs
erschwingbaren Preisen kaufen kann, Grafikkarten sind ein bisschen günstiger geworden, aber
immer noch abfuckteuer, ok bald ist wahrscheinlich Benzin teurer als Grafikkarten, aber das dauert
noch kurz, kommt drauf an was die Commodits treiben, ob es teurer wird oder nicht, ja
einfach so, weil es geht, ich muss kurz meine Emotes einstellen, die sind alle ein bisschen
groß, das wäre doch auch mal ein Feature für meinen Overlay hier oder, dass er sich
merkt welche Größe man eingestellt hat, Michael 5 Spiliaden, nice, auch wieder am Start, 20
Monate, Massive Hypersubscription hier, nice, welches denn das letzte mit X, ich weiß nicht
ob man das hier aussprechen darf auf Twitch, du weißt was ich mein, mit XH, YouTube hat
das Video demonetarisiert, ich musste das letzte Video von mir hier, guck mal, das letzte
Video von mir musste ich allen Ernst 4 mal hochladen, ich hab das Video 4 mal hochgeladen,
ich hab nichts an dem Video gerne, ich hab es 4 mal hochgeladen und zuerst bin ich drauf
gekommen, Porn darf man prinzipiell nicht im Titel erwähnen, das muss man so schreiben,
dann ist ok und man darf weder in der Beschreibung noch im Titel noch in den Tags den Hamster
erwähnen, sobald man den erwähnt, Monetarisierung weg, limited, das Battlefield Rant Video, übrigens
ich liebe Call of Duty Fanboys, kann ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen, guckt
es euch an, guckt es euch einfach an, MW2090 ist eine Vorgeschichte zu Call of Duty, informier
dich mal besser bevor du so ein Dreck von dir kommst, ja genau das hab ich im Video gesagt,
guckt ihr an wie ihr es sich noch geil findet, Call of Duty Fanboys das erinnert mich wirklich
immer an 2011, ich sag euch mal wie es ist, ich sag das ja schon eine Weile und zwar,
die einzige Plattform, der ich es wirklich zutrauen würde, eine Konkurrenz Streaming
Plattform zu Twitch oder eben eine Videoplattform zu Youtube zu machen, ist tatsächlich Pornhub,
allerdings müsste sich natürlich ein bisschen was tun, aber denen würde ich das tatsächlich
zutrauen, stellt euch mal vor die machen Pornhub Gaming oder sowas, das könnte ich mir tatsächlich
vorstellen, das sind die einzigen denen ich das irgendwie noch zutrauen würde, sowas
aus dem Boden zu stampfen, naja gut, das kann man ja auf Twitch fast schon, fast, fast, fehlt
nicht mehr viel, es ist noch ein Streifen Stoff halt drüber, das heißt ja nicht, dass
man dann nur weil das Pornhub Gaming ist, dass es was mit Porn zu tun haben muss und
ja vielleicht sitze ich da nackt im Stream, aber ihr seht mich nicht, insofern ist das
eigentlich auch egal, glaubt mir das wollt ihr wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht sehen,
aber ich kann mir das wirklich vorstellen, dass die sowas, also wenn sie sowas machen
würden, dann, dass es tatsächlich eine Konkurrenz Gamer, nicht ein Mixer oder so ein Kacke,
wo kommt man eigentlich jetzt raus, darf man die Seite überhaupt erwähnen hier, kommt
man da jetzt eigentlich raus, wenn man da hingeht, Doom's Web, Dankeschön für den
Sub, Mysterion, auch danke für den Sub, NMEA730, ja, du willst einen Hyper Subscriber, klar,
ich hab den Sound viel zu laut eingestellt oder, guck mal hier, da fliegen ja die Ohren
weg, Alter, ähm Leute mal eine Frage an euch, ich hab Probleme mit meinen Raspberry Pi 4,
ihr hattet ja auch schon mal Probleme, und zwar, ich hab eine SanDisk Portable, SSD,
sowas da, hab ich an meinem Raspberry Pi dran und ich vermute, ich vermute, dass das nicht
genug Strom über den USB Port bekommt, ich hab da nämlich ein TV Stick dran hängen,
ich wollte mein TV Head and Ding, was wir hier in meinem Stream gebaut haben, umstellen
wir auf den Raspberry Pi, und ich hab da jetzt meinen TV Stick dran mit Dual Tuner und die
SSD und der Raspberry Pi kackt mir nach einer halben Minute ab, mit irgendwelchen SATA-Fehlern
oder sowas, so, ich hab auch das offizielle Raspberry Pi Power Supply dran, 5,1 Volt,
3 Ampere, ich glaube, der Strom von den USB Ports reicht nicht aus, hattet ihr das sowas
schon mal, ich hab leider keinen aktiven USB Hub am Start, um das auszuprobieren, aber
wenn ich es, aber wenn ich es, ähm, an den USB 2 anschließt, ist alles okay, was auch
sinnvoll ist, weil, ähm, dann braucht der nicht so viel Strom, was soll ich, hä, okay,
der Chat hat mir gerade das hier gepostet, äh, was soll ich damit, also, wie genau hilft
mir das jetzt, ja, Moment, du hast die gleiche SSD, aber hast du dann auch einen TV Stick
dran, hast du mehr als ein USB Gerät dran, was auch ein bisschen Strom zieht, ne, ich
benutze den mitgelieferten, ne, ne, ich benutze das offizielle Netzteil, ja, ja, ja, ich
hab lange nicht gestreamt, kein Wolle, dass der IQ getroppt ist im Chat wieder, not stonks,
geht abwärts, Leute, mehrere SSDs, hast du die mal, hast du die mal wirklich volle Pulle,
äh, beide parallel beschrieben, ich glaube, dann hast du wahrscheinlich auch das Problem,
sowas brauchst du, aber warum, warum, warum brauche ich sowas, what the fuck, was, das
ist irgendwie so ein USB Stecker, der mittlerweile schon RIP ist wieder, achso, das ist eins
für Power und eins für, ne, ne, das bringt nichts, der Raspberry Pi kann nicht 1,2 Ampere
an jedem USB Output, der Raspberry Pi kann 1,2 Ampere an allen USB Outputs zusammen,
also sprich, das bringt nichts, wenn ich zwei USB Ports zu einem mache oder so, oder meinst
du damit, dass ich einen davon in das Netzteil an der Wand stecke und einen dann an den Raspberry
Pi und einen in die SSD oder, hä, also angeblich macht der Raspberry Pi 1,2 Ampere auf den
USB Ports, die SSD hat kein Netzteil, die SSD hat genau ein Kabel zum Raspberry Pi,
also ich bräuchte quasi so einen Power Injector oder sowas, falls es sowas gibt, aber da brauche
ich einen extra Netzteil, das ist ziemlich doof, auf allen zusammen 1,2, achso, naja,
warum keinen Power, naja, weil ich eigentlich den Raspberry Pi verwenden wollte, weil es
schön kompakt ist, wenn ich da wieder ein extra Kabel und ein extra, noch ein weiteres
Netzteil in die Wand brauche, ist doof, dann behalte ich mein altes, weil ich habe hier
aktuell so ein Ding im Wohnzimmer stehen für den TV Stick und mit einer SSD drinnen, so
ein Teil, das ist halt, da machst du dir vorne eine SSD rein, hier hinten hast du noch Platz
für einen USB, alles gut und ich wollte das Ding als ablösen durch den Raspberry Pi,
weil der Raspberry Pi einfach deutlich besseren Software Support hat für alles, naja so einfach
ist das nicht, dann müsste ich das ja irgendwie dazwischen klemmen und dann irgendwas, was
was verbraucht dahinter und so, ich denke, es ist höchstwahrscheinlich die Stromversorgung,
wenn nicht, ich muss es mal mit einem aktiven USB Hub ausprobieren, ob das daran liegt,
die GPIO aus, das Verstehen, Zusammenhang Verstehe jetzt nicht, naja gut, wie dem auch
sein hätte sein können, dass einer sagt, ja ich habe das gleiche Problem auch schon
mal, welcher TV Stick, ich habe, das ist ein WimTV Dual Tuner USB, der funktioniert auch
unter Linux, das Teil ist das, das funktioniert auch ohne Probleme unter Linux, solange du
das Firmware File runterlädst von GitHub dafür, ganz ehrlich, ich habe eh keinen Bock mich
da großartig darum zu kümmern, deswegen wollte ich auf den Raspberry Pi umziehen, weil der
Software Support besser ist, ich gucke ja kaum, das ist ja nur für meine Mutter, das ganze
Fernsehding, ich gucke ja kein Fernseh, aber die ist halt etwas, letztes Jahr tausend,
was das angeht, ich kann beispielsweise auch mit der Amazon App nix anfangen, ja da weiß
ich gar nicht, wo ich drücken soll, da gibt es so viel, ja du kannst gucken, was du willst,
ja ach nee, nee, ich mache lieber Fernseh an, ist halt, so ist es halt, sag mal eigentlich
ist es doch extrem diskriminierend, guckt euch das mal an, warum sind sowohl Zoomer
als auch Boomer Bilder alles Männer, können nicht auch Frauen Boomer sein, oder Zoomer,
das muss es doch beides geben, Zoomerinnen und Boomerinnen, genau, ist das das, wo du
mal den Kernel kompiliert hast, exakt, du kannst dich ja noch dran erinnern, ich habe
den Kernel selbst kompiliert, aber es ist halt dumm, ich kriege halt dafür nix Neues
mehr, das System ist uralt, das war mal in Archlinux, hier keine Windows CD Kies oder
sowas posten, das war mal in Archlinux, das kannst du dann mal updaten, das ist so alt
und selbst kompilierter Kram habe ich keinen Bock drauf, deswegen wollte ich den Raspberry
Pi nehmen und dementsprechend mich nicht mehr selbst um irgendwelche Softwaregeschichten
kümmern.
Ja, und, Chat, was bringt mir das jetzt, inwieweit hilft mir das, ich meine, die SSD hängt
immer noch am Raspberry Pi dran, der Raspberry Pi wird immer noch mit dem gleichen Netzteil
mit Strom versorgt, ist auch vollkommen egal in welchem Gehäuse das Ding steckt.
Chat heute, Chat heute, nicht Glanzstunde des Chats heute, das war ein Humble Bundle,
ok, ne ja, der Windows Key ist vorbei, für den Windows Key ist es zu kurz, Leute, wir
machen heute nix, ich bin nur 40 Minuten oder so noch on, ich war jetzt so lange nicht
mehr am Start, ich hab sogar den Aufwachen-Stream ausfallen lassen letzten Sonntag und da hab
ich mir gedacht, ich muss jetzt einfach mal kurz on kommen.
Wie gesagt, ihr merkt es vielleicht immer noch, ich, sagt mal, sagt mal, sagt mal, Chat,
hört man irgendwie den Unterschied, dass es im Hals wieder ein bisschen besser ist mittlerweile?
Also kling ich wieder normaler als, weil letztes Mal haben ja viele gesagt, ich kling nicht
normal, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich kling wieder normaler, klingst wie immer, ja, ich fand
auch das letzte Mal, als ich wie immer geklungen habe, aber manche haben gesagt, nee, nee,
du hörst dich anders an, also atmendechnisch und so muss ich sagen, ist bei mir wieder
alles ok, ich hatte kein Corona, by the way, ja, du klingst wie, ja, das stimmt, das stimmt,
ich hab grad nochmal Wasserdampf-Krams inhaliert, ich bin seit drei, fast über drei Wochen,
klingst mir nicht gut, was das angeht, ist schon wieder ein bisschen besser, das mach
ich jetzt net auf, ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
nix, was mir irgendwie hilft, wir pausen einfach nur, wobei, doch, das, das, das passt zum
Roboter-Kit, tja, wenn man da Spaß dran hat, ist das bestimmt cool, ja, siehste, und trotzdem
hat der IQ des Chats nachgelassen, also an mir kann es nicht gelegen haben, aber ich
hab ihn halt auch nicht weiter aktiv geboostet, dadurch, als ich keine Streams machen konnte,
jo, ansonsten, überleg ich grad, gibt's noch irgendwas spannendes, was in den letzten
Tagen gewesen ist, eigentlich nicht, also die üblichen Sachen, wo sich schon jeder
dazu ausgelassen hat, zum Mord und Totschlag in der Welt will ich mich jetzt hier nicht
äußern, großartig, das gibt's schon überall anders.
Apple-Event werde ich komplett ignorieren, nachdem ich Apple einmal gestrikt hat, nachdem
ich was zum Apple-Event gemacht hab, ehlskibo, dankeschön für den Sub, also, Colonel-Exploit,
tatsächlich, es gibt ein neues Colonel-Exploit, das stimmt, Dirty-Pipe, nennt sich das, ist
aber nur, ja, nur Stufe 1 schlimm, nicht doppelt schlimm, weil du lokale User brauchst,
um das auszuführen, also nicht Remote, aber es ist trotzdem schwerwiegend und sollte gefixt
werden, hab mich aber nicht näher mit beschäftigt, frag mich, wie es auf der Arbeit ist, ob
es da jetzt Emergency Changes gibt, aber wahrscheinlich, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, Elden Ring, tatsächlich,
ich hab's immer noch bei mir installiert, aber noch nicht gespielt, ob das Android betrifft,
meinste, betrifft das Android, das stimmt, theoretisch betrifft, theoretisch, weiß ich
nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, ob das wirklich Android betrifft, theoretisch betrifft das
Android, weil du irgendeine App hast, die sich vielleicht Routerechte erschleichen kann,
das wäre natürlich ziemlich schlecht, und gerade auf Android ist sowas ja auch nicht
patchbar, also, theoretisch schon, aber die Leute haben halt, bei Android haben die halt
8 Jahre alte Betriebssysteme im Einsatz, weil die Hersteller halt keinen Bock haben, nach
2 Monaten zu updaten, das ist ja die Kacke dabei, gibt welche, die machen das besser,
aber ansonsten, Android hast du, komplett, kannst du komplett vergessen, was sowas angeht,
ja, ja, ist echt so, also Android Updates kannst du komplett vergessen, ja, ne, Apple
Events mach ich nix mehr zu, seh das nicht ein, für Apple Werbung zu machen, dann wollen
die mich auch striken hier, ich glaub es geht los, Pech gehabt, was haben wir denn noch
so zu gucken, how to crack any Wi-Fi Password, das ist too easy, Leute, wette, ich wette
mit euch, ich sag euch jetzt wie es ist, ansonsten, gifte ich 10 Subs an den Chat, die ihr dann
alle schön dodgen könnt, ich wette mit euch, dieser Titel ist Chebathe, dieser Titel ist
Chebathe, da geht es entweder darum, also ich predikte das jetzt einfach mal, ich hab
das auch nicht geguckt, also ich predikte jetzt einfach mal 2 Sachen, entweder geht
es da um alte WLAN Geschichten, so WPA1, WEP oder sowas in der Richtung, die hier gerade
WEP, brauchst du irgendwie glaube ich 2,5 Minuten oder so auf einem durchschnittlich
schnellen Laptop, das ist ja wirklich nix, oder aber, oder aber, was ich mir auch vorstellen
könnte ist, er zeigt, wie man jedes Wi-Fi Password cracken kann, aber er definiert ja
keine Zeit, also du kannst ja potentiell jede Verschlüsselung knacken mit genug Zeit,
die Sache ist halt die, dass Zeit jetzt nicht so sich in Zeitrahmen bewegt, wie man das
vielleicht als lang definieren würde, also für uns ist es lang, wenn was ein Jahr dauert,
für Passwortcrackversuche bei einem ordentlich langen Passwort reden wir hier nicht von
einem Jahr, da reden wir hier von Milliarden an Jahren, wir reden teilweise über Zeiträume,
die länger sind als das Universum schon existiert, und ja, das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt,
aber sowas könnte auch sein, naja, also Rainbow Tables funktionieren ja nur unter einem Gesichtspunkt,
dass du kein Salt verwendest, und bei, glaub, bei WLAN Passworten ja prinzipiell schonmal
nicht, aber bei normalen Passwort-Hashes funktioniert das, aber dann auch nur wenn du kein Salt verwendest,
was, es gibt auch ein xkcd für alles, oder, aha, ja, ok, da, wir gucken mal, was wir hier
sehen, wir gucken uns jetzt einfach mal an, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie wir jedes Passwort
cracken können, wenn sowas immer krass, wenn man sich überlegt, dass das knacken länger
dauert als es das Universum gibt, ja, ist so, ist so, oder wenn du auf noch so, wenn du
auf so superlativen Vergleiche stehst, die Möglichkeiten bei einem Passwort mit ausreichender
Länge, also es ist ja immer quasi Zeichenvorrat hoch Passwortlänge, du hast mehr Passwortkombinationen
als es Teilchen im Universum wahrscheinlich gibt, also du kannst ja immer so abgedrehte
Vergleiche zusammen basteln, ja, aber du hast theoretische, mit der aktuellen Technik hast
du Passwörter, die sind nicht innerhalb von 14 Milliarden, also das Universum ist ja ungefähr
14 Milliarden Jahre alt, keine Ahnung, 13,7, 8 oder so, 14 Milliarden Jahre alt, in 14
Milliarden Jahren hast du das nicht geknackt, das ist möglich, ja, ne, er hat ja nicht
Unrecht, also da ist schon was wahres dran, wenn du das Passwortmanager, Masterpasswort
knackst, hast du ein Problem, dann hast du Zugriff auf alles, da ist schon was dran,
auf der anderen Seite kann man das hier absichern, gibt da Möglichkeiten, dass man nicht nur
ein Masterpasswort vergibt, sondern vielleicht auch noch was mit einem, von einem USB Stick
oder was auch immer, man kann das absichern und auf der anderen Seite ist es wahrscheinlich
immer noch besser, Passwortmanager zu verwenden, als Passwörter, die man sich alle im Kopf
merken kann.
Genau, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung ist immer sinnvoll, man muss nämlich sagen, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
bedeutet ja nicht automatisch Passwort und Smartphone, also Smartphone ist halt das,
was heute gerne als Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung verwendet wird, als Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
heißt ja eigentlich nur, dass du zwei verschiedene Passworte, oder besser gesagt zwei verschiedene
Authentifizierungsmethoden verwendest und da kannst du auch ein USB Stick verwenden und
ein Passwort, jo, gibt noch mehr Varianten, USB Stick, wo du dann irgendein Keyfile drauf
hast oder sowas.
Gibt es zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung schon bei Wi-Fi, also bei normalem WPA nicht, bei
WPA Enterprise kannst du ja beliebig gestörte Passwort-Authentifizierungs-Sachen machen,
weil das LDAP-Anbindung hat, bei WPA, bei normalem, also nicht Enterprise WPA, keine
Ahnung.
Ja gut, das, wie gesagt, das geht ja mit Enterprise, mit Enterprise, ich meine übrigens Radius
nicht, LDAP, vergess, ja, das kannst du bei Enterprise WPA machen, aber nicht bei normalem.
Es gibt, also bei Cisco AccessPoint weiß ich, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass du anhand
der MAC-Adresse, ich weiß nicht, ob es anhand der MAC-Adresse ist, aber ich glaube anhand
der MAC-Adresse, des Clients unterschiedliche Passwörter vergeben kannst.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Cisco-Sonderding, das wäre aber eine cooles Feature, aber die
einfachste Variante, zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungen zu machen bei WLAN ist folgende, du machst
ein WLAN, das ganz normal per Passwort geschützt ist und danach ist aber alles per Firewall
geplockt, du kommst nirgendwo hin, auch kleinzeitig untereinander geplockt und dann machst du
ein Portal, also wenn du dich in den WLAN einloggst mit Passwort, bekommst du danach ein Portal
und dort musst du dich dann nochmal authentifizieren, mit einer anderen Authentifizierungsvariante
und erst dann, wenn du dich im Portal authentifiziert hast, erst dann geht die Firewall auf, sowas
könntest du machen, das geht auch mit normalem WPA, da brauchst du kein Enterprise-WPA.
Ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich hab keinen Plastenschimmer von WLAN-Zeug, Dubidai, moin,
oder ja einen schönen Abend, das klingt wie der Tagesschau-Sprecher, schön, dass du
gesubbt hast, aber wir wollten uns ja angucken, wir lassen uns jetzt erklären, wie wir jedes
Passwort cracken und ich schau mal, ob ich richtig predictet habe, was in diesem Video
jetzt ankommt.
Hacker-Loi-Free-WiFi, also ganz im Ernst, wenn ich so eine SSID sehe, connecte ich mich
garantiert nicht, außerdem ich connecte mich prinzipiell zu keinen SSIDs, außer es ist
mein eigenes WLAN.
Was auch wirklich ätzend ist, versucht mal beispielsweise, wenn ihr bei der Telekom seid
und ein iPhone habt, versucht mal dieses automatische Joinen, das Telekom, der Telekom Hotspots
abzuschalten, ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das ist übertreibbar, ok, jetzt kriegen wir es beigebracht.
Was?
Seriously?
Das soll Monitoring heißen?
Also ich meine, meine Handschrift ist schon kacke und ich würde es wahrscheinlich genauso
schreiben, aber...
Leute, Leute, ich darf mich übrigens über Handschrift oder über Schreibschrift von
anderen überhaupt nicht mehr beschweren, weil ich kann nicht mehr schreiben, ich kann
nicht mehr schreiben, mit der Hand geschreit, wie ging das, wenn ich, wie macht man denn
X?
So?
Ich kann keine Schreibschrift mehr, ich kann auch mit der Hand keine Schreibschrift
mehr, ich kann immer Hallo schreiben, hallo?
Ich kann es nicht mehr, ich bin, ich habe 20 Jahre nicht mehr mit der Hand richtig geschrieben,
ich kann nicht mehr schreiben, mit der Hand.
Was?
Das ist ja auch nicht schwierig.
Das Wichtigste, erstmal, bevor wir überhaupt anfangen, wobei schauen wir mal weiter, bevor
ich jetzt was erzähle, ich schaue noch weiter.
Ok?
Ja gut, das alleine bringt einem ja noch nichts.
Huge exciting.
Ok.
WIFI HACKING TECHNIQUE
auf euren Nachbarn, auf einige Leute, die keine Ahnung, woher sie herkommen
gegen solche WIFI Netzwerke
bitte macht das nicht
denn das wird in Schwierigkeit kommen
Also ich habe meine Zweifel, dass es überhaupt irgendjemand merken würde, wenn du dich auf die Straße stellst mit deinem Notebook, WLAN Packages capturesst und dann im Ende dann dein Notebook mit Grafikkarte drauf ansetzt
aber ja man darf es vielleicht nicht, wobei ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ist das reine Cracken von aufgezeichneten, also ist das reine Rausfinden des Passworts schon illegal oder erst wenn ich mich einlogge danach
und ist es überhaupt illegal wenn ich nichts kaputt mache
für eine Subskription, damit dein WIFI nicht verhackt wird
also hier vor uns und wir sind in Karlonix
und gleichzeitig habe ich mich mit einem separaten WIFI-Auditing-Plattform, welches Pineapple genannt ist
also das gibt uns die Möglichkeit, dass ein WIFI-Attack vorhanden ist
und übrigens kannst du es mit jedem WIFI-Adapter machen, solange du den richtigen WIFI-Adapter hast
also es war Spaß beiseite, also Kali Nielungs wird da wirklich gerne verwendet
es zeigt sich, wow, ok, der hat wohl wirklich Plan
toll, ich will vielleicht nicht so drüber lustig warten
ok, ja
ok, er hat sein Netzwerkinterface rausgefunden
das Interface
ok, jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich ein paar Pakete mitschneiden vermutlich
ok, da siehst du alle SSIDs und die MAC-Adressen der Access Points
wo geht es denn los?
ok, alles da, jetzt schneide ich eine WLAN-Pakete mit
ok, das ist ein Capture-File, was er alles mitgeschnitten hat
ok, wann geht dann das Gehecke los jetzt?
wie?
Word-List? Ich dachte, wir erfahren jetzt, wie wir jedes x-beliebige Passwort hacken können
ja, mit einer Wörterliste kann ich das auch
ok, ich brauche eine neue Terminale
ok, mal gucken, was interessantes kommt
gar das Capture-File
ernsthaft, Wörterliste, come on
ich dachte, da kommt jetzt wirklich ein bisschen was mit mehr Substanz
ich meine, Wörterliste, das kriegt er nur im, ja, brauchst du nicht mal ein gutes Notebook für
also wenn das funktioniert, ist sein WLAN-Passwort wahrscheinlich abcdef oder 123456 oder hallo123-root-root-root oder irgendwie sowas
Justin aus Lorneberg sagt, bitte hack mich nicht, das ist ganz einfach, dazu mussten wir erstmal ein Prime-Sub dalassen
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
in scp-move hast du nicht gecheckt, er hat sein Capture-File rüberkopiert, warum, keine Ahnung
wahrscheinlich weil er es dort gecaptured hat, wo er das am Ende nicht auswertet oder so
wahnsinn
und lass mich raten, der Rat ist, verwendet ein ausreichend komplexes Passwort
was, nein
ja, jetzt müssen wir das übertreiben komplett
ich mein, er hat Recht, ja
er hat Recht
ich mein
hallo
das hat mich jetzt erschreckt
so genau habe ich mir den Step nicht angeguckt, ich hab gedacht, er hat sein Capture-File rüberkopiert auf ein Rechner, weil er gecaptured hat auf dem Notebook mit WLAN oder so
ich mein, er hat nicht Recht, du kannst potenziell mit dieser Art und Weise mehr oder weniger jedes Passwort knacken, wenn du was anderes als eine Wörterliste oder so nimmst
du kannst ja auch wirklich dran gehen mit Tools, die dir im Endeffekt dann die Grafikkarte durchbrennen lassen und du wirst trotzdem nicht rausfinden
ich mein, es kommt auf die Zeit an, wenn du 5 Milliarden Jahre Zeit hast, kannst du jedes Passwort knacken
das YouTube, naja, nur wenn es wirklich Hacker-Content ist, es sei denn es ist Educational, Educational ist erlaubt, das Problem ist, dass die YouTube-Bewertungsleute sich sehr schwer damit zu tun, zu erkennen, was ist echt das Hacking-Video, was ist ein Educational-Hacking-Video
ist nö, es ist überhaupt nichts Neues bei, deswegen kommt man das Video eigentlich komplett knicken, wenn man es mal so will, was hat uns denn hier, Dice Ads Scoreboard, Nobody Left To Kill, ach ja, weil wir letzten, wir haben es letzten Sonntag ja versäumt, die üblichen Geschichten müssen wir uns mal angucken
es wird ja immer schlimmer, es wird ja immer schlimmer, das ist so schlecht man, 2350 Spiek, ist dein Husten besser
also ich muss immer ein bisschen husten und ich hab immer noch Kratzen im Hals, aber was gut ist, ich kann wieder halbwegs nochmal atmen jetzt mittlerweile, ist besser und es war kein Corona
schon hydratet, ja ich hab hier extra stehen
ja, also das ist wirklich mal wieder komplett im Arsch
was sind PMF
wie gesagt, ich habe von WLAN Sachen keine Ahnung, was ist PMF
der Prize Champ, der ist down, den habe ich abgeschaltet, nein ich bin krank, seit ich war vor drei Wochen fast die ganze Woche krank
ich war letzte Woche Freitag krank und jetzt noch die ganze Woche, weil mein Husten nicht besser wird, ich bin ja schon froh, dass ich jetzt wieder normal Luft kriege
deswegen streame ich auch nicht so viel, aber jetzt mal die Stunde heute Abend geht schon
C++ Meinung, das meinst du nicht ernst, sondern das ist debate, du bist so lange schon dabei, du weißt genau, dass du mit dieser Frage irgendwas
sag mal, hast du dich umbenannt, hieß du vorher anders, der Name sagt mir nämlich so gar nichts
wenn du so lange dabei bist, hast du dich umbenannt, hieß du, hieß du vorhin, ich wusste es, dass du das warst
ich wusste es, dass du das warst, weil Leku schon öfters diese debate C++ Frage gestellt hat, ich wusste es, dass du das warst
Protected Management aka 802.11w, monkaW, nee, keine Bewerbung, die Bewerbung ist doch nicht raus, nee
wo wollte ich gar nicht hin, so also jetzt haben wir uns die aktuellen Spielzahlen von Belfin angeguckt
meins, moin, hast du Tipps für ein Bewerbungsgespräch hinter IT, so pauschal ist das immer schwierig
kommt auf die Firma an, wo du dich bewirbst, also eine Sache, die prinzipiell nicht verkehrt ist, wenn man sich ein bisschen in die Gegenseite reinversetzt
und sich im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen überlegt, so nach dem Motto, ok, was ist das für ein Laden, kann sich auch mal angucken, was suchen die sonst noch so für Stellen, vielleicht nicht nur das, was dich jetzt halt interessiert hat
und ja, was könnten die erwarten, was machen die so, sich den Laden ein bisschen angucken und sich vielleicht schon die ein oder anderen Themen, das finde ich tatsächlich ganz praktisch
schon die ein oder anderen Themen im Vorfeld zurechtlegen, die ganz gut dazu passen, weil es gibt nichts blöderes, wenn man erstmal da sitzt und sich alle quasi die erste Minute anguckt
und keiner genau weiß, wer jetzt was wie wo sagen soll und dann ist besser, du hast ein gutes Thema als die Fragen durch irgendeinen Kack
aber ansonsten kann man das sehr schwierig sagen
was ist eigentlich aus deinem i3 System geworden, das ist noch da, hier guck
das ist noch da, da ist es
am Start, so
der Desktop ist way to dank, ja, der Desktop ist high IQ only, da brauchst du viele Prime Subs, bis man da durchblickt auf die Schnelle
ah wie, danke für den Sub, danke für den, gut, war ja noch gar keiner so wirklich, aber danke für den Sub, also wenn du was spezielles wissen willst, bzw. irgendwann ein bisschen mehr Details verraten willst, kann ich vielleicht noch mehr zu sagen, so ist aber schwierig
ja, manche haben Glück, manche sind Naturtalente, ihren Kram zu verkaufen, hier guck mal, die 3 System ist noch am Start
warum benutzt man freiwillig Windows, ja z.B. wenn du Sachen spielen willst, wenn du Content Creator bist und Videos machen willst, dann kannst du das auch machen
warum benutzt man freiwillig Windows, ja z.B. wenn du Sachen spielen willst, wenn du Content Creator bist und Videos machen willst von Spielen bzw. Sachen aufnehmen, Sachen schneiden, Thumbnails bearbeiten und kein Bock hast auf fucking GIMP unter Linux, dann bleibt dir ja nicht viel anderes übrig, gut, weil du kannst ja ein Mac holen, das würde auch funktionieren, aber dann ist mit dem Spielen auch nichts
und dann hast du 3 Systeme anstatt 2
im Prinzip ist ganz einfach, man sollte das verwenden, was am besten ist für das, was man machen will
und dementsprechend verwende ich die Sachen, die unter Windows gut funktionieren, unter Windows und den Rest mache ich einfach in meiner Linux, weil es halt deutlich einfacher ist, Linux unter Windows zu virtualisieren, also umgedreht
oh, warum ist die Musik aus, wo ist eigentlich die Musik aus
guck mal, nee, das ist alles Desktop System, sag das nicht so laut, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es da schon irgendwelche Projekte auf GitHub gibt
kannst du wahrscheinlich dann die Grafikkarte forwarden über PCI Express auf der IP, Moment, Moment, Moment, jetzt wo ich das sage, gibt es sowas?
ernsthaft?
the fuck?
PCI Express auf der IP, ich glaube es nicht, geil, bewerben, es ist ein IT-Systemhaus, welches für Kunden, das machen sie ja alle, das machen ja mehr oder weniger alle
wenn du vielleicht rauskriegst bei denen auf der Seite, was die so verwenden, dann ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt, wenn man da schon ein paar schlaue Sprüche zu den einzelnen Sachen loswerden kann
MineOS läuft auf einem Minecraft-Taschenrechner, ja, wer kennt das nicht, die Redstone-Virtualisierung
oh, Mist, ja, nee, Sonntag musste ich zu sehr husten noch, ich hoffe jetzt wirklich, dass es langsam besser wird
Ach ja, wir waren da bei den Spielerzahlen, wie sieht es mit New World aus?
das ist ja beides, wirklich, Hail auf ähnlichem Niveau, ja
oh man, ja gut, das ist zehnmal mehr als Battlefield, aber die haben auch mit zehnmal mehr als Battlefield gestartet, auf Steam, also so einen großen Unterschied macht das gar nicht an Spielerzahlen
was ein Versagen, Alter, bei diesen zwei Sachen, was will uns jetzt eigentlich Level Cap, komm wir lassen uns eine Runde noch von Level Cap chibaden
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so, ich meine, das kann man so sehen, kann man so sehen, dass das verkackt ist, eine weitere Sache, wo wohl ziemlich versagt werden muss aktuell, ist Age of Empires IV
ich selbst spiele, das hat sich jetzt angehört wie die letzte Assi-Ansage, ich selbst spiele keinen Age of Empires IV, aber ich gucke ganz gern den einen oder anderen Streamer, der Age of Empires IV spielt
und die sind im Prinzip eigentlich ja nicht sonderlich zufrieden und das Game hat wohl mittlerweile schon so viele Spieler eingebüßt, dass es auch quasi wieder weniger Spieler hat als der Vorgänger oder als der Vorvorgänger
Bist du der, der sich Semper-Video auf YouTube, was, ich habe mich noch nicht mal entfernt an wie Semper-Video, außer ich sage immer, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, aber ansonsten höre ich mich weder an wie Semper-Video, noch habe ich was mit Semper-Video zu tun
Was hältst du vom Comeback der analogen Rechner? Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass da irgendetwas Comebackt
Mark L.D.M. Danke für den Sub
Ja wir wollen uns Level Cap angucken noch
Okay, Level Cap, wo bist du?
Wait a minute, Level Cap hat mal normales Gameplay? Ach nee gegen Bots, anstatt immer das gleiche Preview-Material
Bots, keck Wade, alter, wer macht denn sowas?
Ah Moment, es ist Level Cap, ich habe das verwechselt mit, nee, doch Level Cap, ich schmeiß die alle durcheinander
Achso, du hast einmal ausgebildet, ich habe keine Zeit für 2. MMO-Kreise, client
Danke für den Sub, ja da hat die Welt natürlich drauf gewartet jetzt
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, auf so einen Cosmetic-Pack, ich meine mal ernsthaft, das Game ist nicht nur unfertige Haufen Kacke, der nicht besser wird
Das hat auch mit Abstand die schlechtesten und billigsten Cosmetics, die ich glaube ich in fast jedem Game, was auf Cosmetics setzt, gesehen habe
Was ist denn das? Was ist denn das? Was ist denn das?
Das ist doch Müll, wobei man halt sagen muss, im Prinzip ist der Skin immer noch besser als der Weihnachts-Skin oder der Cowboy-Skin oder sowas oder sogar besser als der normale Skin, der sieht nach futuristischem Soldat jetzt wenigstens aus
Aber trotzdem, das geht ja noch, aber das hier, also mal ehrlich, das ist Level 37,5 in einem Season Pass, wo man nicht wusste was man da reinstecken soll
Ernsthaft, am Ende der Runde kann man nicht mehr reingucken, ja das ist Absicht, ich sag doch das Hat-System, ich hab das schon in einem der ersten Videos bei mir gesagt, das ist absichtlich nicht drin gewesen
Danach haben sie gesagt, das ist ein Legacy-Feature, man hat sich bewusst dafür entschieden, es nicht reinzupacken, dass die Leute nicht sehen, wenn sie schlecht sind
Deswegen gibt es das jetzt auch am Ende nicht, erinnert sich noch jemand an Battlefield 3, da wurde am Ende das Scoreboard einfach eingeplendet, ungefragt, von sich aus, so muss das ja auch sein, das ist ja Rundenende, wozu gibt es sonst Rundenende? Ja geil, zum Cringe-Sprüche machen
Aber ich möchte das Scoreboard unbedingt checken, das Feature kommt im April-Patch, das Scoreboard selbst
Ein Monat für einen fucking Patch, was das Scoreboard im Outro-Screen anzeigt, oder was? Eine güde Mann
Naja ein Level-Cap, man hätte ja durchaus machen können, dass man gerade im End-Screen durchtappen kann, was man sehen will, dass man sagen will, ich möchte Score sehen, ich möchte Fahrzeug-Kill sehen, ich möchte Fahrzeug-Damage sehen, ich möchte Kill sehen, ich möchte Assist sehen, das hätte man ja durchaus machen können, aber da ist DICE nicht dazu in der Lage
Season 1 kommt irgendwann, fragt mich nicht im Juni oder so, so schlecht, so schlecht, vor allem jetzt haben sie ja Bots am Start, jetzt können sie sagen, warum, die Servers sind doch bevölkert, guckt mal da, permanente Action, 70% sind halt Bots
Dadurch, dass du keinen gescheiten Server-Browser hast, kannst du noch nicht mal sagen, Jungs, wir treffen uns jetzt da
Es ist, oh Gott, es ist so fail, es ist wirklich ein komplette, also über Battlefield 2042 könnte irgendein Stonks-Management-Typ ein Buch schreiben, wie man das nicht macht und damit wahrscheinlich viel Geld verdienen
Ist doch geil, oder, ein Skin, ein Skin und ein Scoreboard, hui, krasses Feature Pack, Mann
Warum redet man überhaupt noch über das Game, ich glaube das liegt daran, also ich kann dir zumindest sagen, warum es mich noch interessiert, weil ich einfach Battlefield-Fan seit Jahren bin und komplett enttäuscht wurde von dem Game und jetzt bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig
Außer noch ein bisschen drauf rumzuhacken und meinem Ärger Luft zu machen, weil besser wird es nicht mehr
Ich glaube, es ist ein wirklicher Kopf-Scratcher, wie die Optik von DICE, dass sie eine einzelne Feature zu dem Spiel geben, die nicht wirklich funktioniert, während einer der wichtigsten Zeiten ist, dass es funktionieren sollte, ist nicht großartig
Now don't get me wrong, I want DICE to fix this game, even if it takes them a long time, I hope they can... Nein, DICE wird dieses Game niemals fixen, ich glaube das sollten mittlerweile alle realisiert haben, entweder machen sie Anthem 2.0 Move daraus, das glaube ich aber nicht
Ich glaube eher, dass es einen langsamen und stillen Tod sterben wird, Battlefield 2042, nämlich es wird das geliefert, was versprochen wurde, im Vorfeld quasi auch verkauft wurde mit den limited Editions, die es da so gab, oder sie waren nicht limited, mit den special Editions, die es da so gab
Und es wird darüber hinaus nichts zusätzlich mehr gemacht, nichts. Wartet mal Season 1 ab, wenn Season 1 überhaupt nennenswert kommt mit Inhalten, oder wenn Season 1 überhaupt kommt, dann wird das wahrscheinlich die letzte Season werden
Oder, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ne es wird nicht die letzte Season werden, weil sie haben doch gesagt sie deliveren 4 Seasons im Jahr oder so, ja dann wird es halt noch weitere 3 Seasons geben, ohne dass was passiert
Kannst du ein Außenthermometer empfehlen? Ähm, ich hab eins, aber das ist Sea-Wave, das ist nicht Zigbee
There are reasons for things being slow at DICE, and the best case scenario that I can come up with is that all effort is being put into a soft relaunch of the game, making the patches leading up to that seeming
Also ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr mit ihm gesprochen, aber ich gehe stark davon aus, dass er nicht gestorben ist in der Zwischenzeit, wobei es ist ja aktuell, weiß man ja nie, aber ich denke dem gehts gut
Ja, die Aquara Sensoren sind gut, aber die sind meistens nicht für Outdoor gedacht
Es ist so fake, guck mal, dass das alles Bots sind
Und ein Softlaunch, das hab ich ja auch in einem Video von mir schon gesagt, dass ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass sie das quasi noch mal bringen als free to play
Die Sache ist nur die, selbst free to play Spiele haben einen gewissen Anspruch, und Battlefield 2042 erfüllt noch nicht mal den Anspruch von free to play Spielern
Ich mein es ist free, aber es ist sehr wenig to playens Wertes dabei
Was ich für Z-Wave außen verwende, ich verwende einen, boah wie heißt das Ding, Fibaro Multisensor oder sowas in der Richtung
Nein nicht das Ding, nicht Saurons Auge, sieht doch echt so aus oder
Ich verwende, wo ist der denn, Z-Wave Multisensor, der ist da, den da hab ich draußen, auf der Fensterbank liegen
Den da hab ich auf der Fensterbank liegen, geht per Akku, aber ich hab ihn auch am USB Kabel dran, es wird ein dünnes Kabel mitgeliefert, was du ohne Probleme durchs Fenster machen kannst
Das coole an dem ist, du hast Temperatur, du hast Licht, du hast, was hast du noch mehr, Luftfeuchtigkeit und steht so
Motion, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Thermometer, Licht, UV, ok brauchst du alles nicht, Motion bei mir auf der Fensterbank, useless, Luftfeuchtigkeit, kann man sich angucken
Wichtig ist in dem Fall Thermometer und ob es hell oder dunkel ist, der Rest ist eigentlich egal
Den finde ich aber ganz gut, das war nicht einer der, ich glaube das war sogar der erste Sensor, den ich mir damals gekauft habe
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich würde nach anderen gucken, wenn du schon Zigbee am Start hast, ich würde jetzt nicht noch mit Z-Wave und einem Z-Wave Stick anfangen
Wenn du schon Zigbee hast, es gibt garantiert auch gute Outdoor Zigbee Temperature Sensor
Mal gucken, die Aquara Dinger, Aquara, ich verkam immer nicht merken wie man den schreibt, die Dinger sind ja nicht für Outdoor gedacht
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass die Outdoor sogar funktionieren, wenn du die ein bisschen abdichtest oder so
Wobei halt die Sache ist, Luftfeuchtigkeit abgedichtet geht halt wieder nicht
Ich denke du kannst den Aquara Sensor ohne Probleme draußen hinhängen, solange du ihn nicht da hinhängst, wo es direkt drauf regnet
Ansonsten tja, müssen wir mal nach Erfahrungswerten gucken
Wir gucken uns das Level Cap Video jetzt nicht weiter an, weil im Prinzip kommt da nichts neues
So sieht es aus
Ich will jetzt nicht so viel schwätzen, weil Hals und so
Welchen hast du? Den normalen Aquara Temperature Sensor?
Nice, nice
Das ist nicht praktisch, wenn ich seitdem ich den Pop-Schutz drauf habe, auch wenn ich jetzt mal ein bisschen lauter ausatmen muss oder so
Man hört es kaum, wegen dem Pop-Schutz
Ein Pock-Schutz sozusagen
Moin, die Sache ist die, ich gehe jetzt off, Leute
War wie gesagt, kurzer Stream, wollte mich einfach nur mal wieder melden, dass ich noch lebe
Und ich werde jetzt echt gucken, ich weiß nicht ob ich am Wochenende streamen werde
Ich werde jetzt halt gucken, dass das mit meinem Hals hoffentlich wieder alles okay ist in den nächsten paar Tagen
Du hast nicht wirklich was verpasst, ne?
Oder ansonsten, Leute gibt es doch irgendwas wichtiges, wo ich was zu sagen müsste
Irgendwas spannendes, irgendwas, wozu ich unbedingt mein Selbst zugeben sollte
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Zumindest nichts, was man jetzt mal kurz in zwei Minuten abfackeln kann
Apple Event, habe ich nicht geguckt, werde ich mich auch nicht mit beschäftigen
Nachdem ich Apple einmal gestrikt habe, sehe ich das nicht ein
Pech gehabt
Aber der Gelegenheit, Leute, ich gucke mal gerade in meine Business-Mails, das kann ich ja immer nur von hier gescheit machen
Wenn ich hier in dem, bzw. nicht in dem Account, wenn ich den anderen Rechner an habe
Mein Thunderbird geht nicht auf
Warum?
Ich habe Oldschool-Thunderbird-E-Mail-Programm
Denkst du, jetzt kommen die russischen Hacker-Mans und legen die Industrie lahm?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, sie versuchen es
Beziehungsweise haben da auch schon kleinere Erfolge gehabt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie im großen Stil da was machen können überhaupt
Also wenn die russischen Hacker-Mans so gut funktionieren wie die russischen Panzer, dann wird das wahrscheinlich nichts
So, mal kurz Business-Mails gucken
Aha, mir schickt jemand Stellenanzeigen
Interessant
Oh, Wobblors hat eine Mail bekommen
Was für ein Ding, irgendein China-Chinesen-Zeug
Keine Ahnung
Verstehe ich nicht, was die von mir wollen
Und irgendein komisches, keine Ahnung, was ist denn wieder nur Mist dabei
Ok Leute, wir sehen uns
Ich gehe jetzt auf, bis denn, CU, alles gut, vielleicht sehen wir uns die Tage wieder, wenn Halstechnisch und so alles besser ist
Bis denn